so let's talk about the most recent
choice
made by vladimir putin
the choice to invade ukraine or to
escalate the invasion of ukraine on
february 24th 2022
now we're a few months removed
from that decision initial decision
why do you think he did it what are the
errors
in understanding the situation and
calculating the outcomes
and um
everything else about this decision in
your view
yeah lex when you don't when a war
doesn't go well
it looks like
lunacy to have launched it in the first
place does it ever go well
war never goes according to plan
all war is based upon miscalculation
but not everybody is punished for their
miscalculation
all aggressive war we're talking about
not defensive war
is based upon miscalculation
but you can adjust you can recalibrate
you know when when you're driving down
the road and that very annoying voice is
telling you in a thousand
feet make a right yeah and you fail to
make a right it recalibrates right yeah
it tells you okay now you know go uh
turn around or u-turn or make a left it
doesn't say you're an idiot and turn
around and make a u-turn but it does
recalibrate
so you can miscalculate and the problem
is not the miscalculation usually it's
the failure to do that adjustment right
people i know who are
hedge fund
traders
they i asked them you know what's your
favorite trade and the line from them
all this is a cliche is my favorite
trade is when i made a mistake
but i got out early
before all the carnage
so their favorite trade is not when they
made some brilliant choice
but it's when they miscalculated but
they reduced the consequences of their
miscalculation by recalibrating quickly
right
so let's talk about the calculation and
miscalculation of february
let's imagine lex that you've been
getting away with murder
i don't mean murder in a figurative
sense i mean you've been murdering
people
you've been murdering them domestically
and you've been murdering them all
across europe and you've been murdering
them not just with for example
a car accident a staged car accident
or using a handgun
you use novichok
or you use some other
internationally outlawed chemical weapon
and let's imagine that you did it and
nothing happened to you
it wasn't like you were removed from
power it wasn't like you paid a personal
price sure maybe there was some
sanctions on your economy but you didn't
pay the price of those sanctions
little people paid the price of those
sanctions
other people in your country paid the
prices let's imagine not only were you
murdering people literally
but you decided
to
entice the idiotic ruler of georgia
into a provocation
that you could then invade the country
and you invaded the country and you bit
off these territories abkhazia and south
ossetia
and what price did you pay for that
and then you decided you know
i think i'll now invade crimea and
forcibly annex crimea and i'll
instigate an insurrection in the donbass
in eastern ukraine in luhansk let's
imagine you did all that and then you
had to stick out your wrist so that you
know
it could be slapped a couple of times
and you said you know i can pretty much
do what i want
they're putting a sanction here and
there and they're doing this and they're
doing that and and you know what they're
more energy dependent on me than before
i get better money laundering and
reputation services than anybody has
maybe the middle east and the chinese
would disagree with you that that you
have better than them but yours are
pretty good and the panama papers get
released revealing
all of your offshoring and your
corruption and and what happened nothing
happens lex so the first and most
important consideration here is in your
own mind
you've been getting away with murder
literally
as well as figuratively and you think
you know i probably can do something
again and get away with it
and so the failure to respond at scale
in fact the indulgences
the further dependencies that are
introduced the illusion
that trade is the mechanism to manage
authoritarian regimes
you know that great a german cliche
a van del doychandel
change through
trade or transformation through trade
one of angela merkel's favorite
expressions
right you're you're gonna get the other
side
to be better
rather than confront them
in a cold war fashion
where you stand up to their aggressions
and you punish them severely in order to
deter further behavior
so that's the first and most important
part of the calculation miscalculation
there are a lot of other dimensions so
can we pause on that really quick
so this is kind of idea of it's okay to
crack a few eggs to make an omelet
um which is a more generous description
of what you're saying
that
you don't incorporate into the
calculation
the amount of human suffering that the
decisions cause
but instead you look at sort of
the success based on some kind of
measure for you personally
and
for the nation
in not in terms of in the humanitarian
sense but in some kind of economic sense
and a power geopolitical power sense
yeah
you're not sentimental x
you say to yourself
the cause of russian greatness
is greater than any individual life
russia being in the first rank of the
great powers russia realizing its
mission
to be
a special country with a special mission
in the world a civilization unto itself
the first rank of the great powers maybe
even the greatest power that's worth
the price
that we have to pay especially in other
people's lives right
we have a lot of literature on the putin
regime which talks about the kleptocracy
the places of kleptocracy and it is a
kleptocracy
we all can see that
and anybody in london
living the high life
servicing this kleptocracy can testify
that it's a kleptocracy and not only in
london of course right here in the
united states in new york
but you know it's not only a kleptocracy
lex
that was the problem of the russian
studies literature
it wasn't just about stealing looting
the state
it was about russian greatness
you see those rituals in the kremlin
right in the grand kremlin palace
in the saint george's hall
some of the greatest interiors in the
world
and you see awards ceremonies and you
see marking holidays and all of these
looters of the state have their uniforms
on with their medals
and someone's given a speech or singing
a ballad and their eyes are moist
their eyes are moist
because they're thieves and looters
no legs because they believe in russian
greatness
they have a deep and fundamental
passionate commitment to the greatness
of russia
which in unsentimental fashion they're
all sentimental to the max that's why
their
their eyes are moistening but they
imagine unsentimentally that any
sacrifice is okay a sacrifice of other
people's lives
a sacrifice of their conscripts in the
military a sacrifice of ukrainian women
and children and elderly that's a small
price to pay
for those moist eyes about russian
greatness and russia's position in the
world well that human thing that
sentimentality is the thing that can get
us in trouble in the united states as
well
and lead us to wars the illegal wars and
so on but the united states has
repercussions
for
breaking the law
you're going to pay for illegal wars in
the end
you're saying that in authoritarian
regimes
this some sentimentality can really get
out of hand and you can by charismatic
leaders they can take that to manipulate
the populace to make uh to that in in
the span of history led to atrocities
and uh in today's world lead to
humanitarian crises
it's not just a kleptocracy it's a
belief system it's passion it's
conviction
it's it's it's
you can call them illusions you can call
them fantasies
whatever you want to call them they're
real they're real for those people and
so yes they're looting that very state
that they're trying to make one of the
great powers in the world and they
resent
the fact that the west doesn't
acknowledge them as one of those great
powers and they resent that the west is
more powerful
people talk about how putin doesn't
understand
the world and that he gets really bad
information alex if you're sitting there
in that kremlin
and you're trying to conduct business in
the world and you're getting reports
from your finance minister or your
central bank governor
your whole economy everything that
matters somehow all your trade is
denominated in dollars and euros
do you have any illusions about who
controls the international financial
system i don't think so lex
you looking over your industrial plan
for the next year
and you're looking over how many tanks
you're going to get and how many cruise
missiles you're going to get and how
many submarines you're going to get and
and and fill in the blank
and you know what
it says right there in the paperwork
where the component parts come from
where the software comes from comes from
the west lex
your whole military-industrial complex
is dependent on high-end western
technology
and then and let's and let's say you're
in beijing not just in moscow and you go
to a meeting in your own neighborhood
you're the leader of china
you go to a meeting with other asian
leaders
do they all speak in chinese with you
no lex they don't speak chinese
you go to an international meeting as
the leader of china and guess what
language is the main language of
intercourse
yes the same one you and i are speaking
right now
and so you live in that world you live
in the western world and it's very hard
to have illusions about what world you
live in
when you're under that you need those
western banks
you need that foreign currency right you
need that high-end western technology
that technology transfer
you're speaking or you're forced to
speak or your minions are forced to
speak at international gatherings in
english
and and i could go on all the indicators
that you live in and so putin lives in
that world he's no fool
well to push back isn't it possible that
as you said the minions
operate in that world
but can't you if you're the leader of
russia or the leader of china or the
leader of these different nations
still put up walls where actually when
you think in the privacy of your own
mind you exist not in the international
world
but in a world where there's this great
russian empire or this great chinese
empire yes and then you forget that
there's english you forget that there's
technology and iphones you forget that
there's all this
uh
us keeps popping up on all different
paperwork that just becomes the blurry
details that dissipate because what
matters is the greatness
of this dream
empire that i have in my mind as a
dictator
i would put it this way lex after you
absorb
all of that
from your minions
and and it impresses upon your
consciousness
where you live
you live in a western dominated world
that the multipolar world doesn't exist
your goal is to make that multipolar
world exist
your goal is to bring down the west
your goal is for the west to weaken
your goal is a currency other than the
dollar in the euro
your goal is is an international
financial system that you dominate your
goal is technological self-sufficiency
made in china 2035 right
your goal is a world that you dominate
not that the west dominates and you're
going to do everything you can
to try to attain that world
which is a russian-centric world or a
chinese-centric world or what we could
call a eurasian-centric world
and it's not going to be easy lex just
for the reasons that where we enumerated
before
but maybe you're going to get a helping
hand
maybe the west is going to transfer
their best technology to you they're
going to sell you their best stuff
and then you're going to absorb it and
maybe copy it and reverse engineer it
and and if they won't sell it to you
maybe you'll just have to steal it
maybe the west is going to allow you to
bank even though
you violate many laws
that would prohibit the west from
extending those banking services to you
maybe the west is gonna buy your energy
and your palladium and your titanium and
your rare metals like lithium because
you're willing to have your poor people
mine that stuff
and die of disease at an early age but
western governments they don't want to
do that right they don't want to do that
dirty mining of those very important
rare earths but you're willing to do
that because it's just people whose
lives you don't care about as an
autocratic regime right so that's the
world you live in where
you're trying to get to this other world
you're
at the center of the other world you
dominate the other world but the only
way to get their lex
is the west
has to weaken divide itself
maybe even collapse
and so you're encouraging to the extent
possible
western divisions you know western
disunity
a western lack of resolve
uh western mistakes and west invasion of
the wrong country and and western
destruction of its credibility through
international financial crises and
one could go on so the if the west
weakens itself through its mistakes and
its own corruption
you're going to survive and maybe even
come out into that world
where you're the center and so russia's
entire grand strategy just like china's
grand strategy iran it's hard to say
they have a grand strategy because
they're so
so profoundly weak
but russia's grand strategy is we're a
mess
we don't invest in our human capital our
human capital flees or we actually drive
it out
it goes to mit
like you did or it goes to fill in the
blank right
we can't invest in our people our health
care is terrible our education system is
in decline
we don't build infrastructure likes
we don't improve our governance
we don't invest in those attributes of
modern power that make the west powerful
we can't because when we try the money
is stolen
we try these grandiose projects of
national projects they're called we're
going to invest in higher ed we're going
to invest in high tech we're going to
build our own silicon valley known as
kolkovo we're going to do all those
things in what happens
they can't even build an airport without
the money disappearing the sochi olympic
selects
it costs them officially cost them 50
billion dollars you look around at the
infrastructure that endured
from that 50 billion dollar expense
and you're thinking you know that's like
the second avenue subway you get almost
nothing for your money
and so yeah it's corruption legs but
it's also because they don't want to do
that
they don't want to invest in their
people
they couldn't do it if they wanted to
and when they try it doesn't work
but why invest in your own people
invest in your hardware your military
hardware
right invest in your cyber
capabilities
invest in all your spoilation techniques
and your hard power
and invest in
further corrupting and further weakening
and further dividing the west
because as i said if the west is weak
divided lacking resolve
you don't invest in your people you
don't build infrastructure you don't
improve your governance but you'll
muddle through
that's russian grand strategy so
invest in the hard power
weaken the west those combined together
means you're going to be
incentivized to escalate
any military aggressive conflicts
that are around you or create new ones
or if you can get away with murder but
what happens lex if it's a harry
truman-like response
what happens if somebody says you know
we're going to stand up to this
we're not going to allow this to happen
we're not going to launder your money
anymore
we're not going to be dependent on you
for energy in the long term we're going
to make a transition
we're going to punish you for that kind
of behavior instead and and the west is
now switched to that
only because
of the
courage and ingenuity of the ukrainian
people the ukrainian resistance
to russian aggression
was one of the greatest gifts the west
has ever received
the sacrifices that the ukrainians are
making
right now as we speak
meaning they're fighting a war
by themselves against the major military
power their neighbor russia
nobody's fighting it with them yes
we are giving them weapons so they can
conduct self-defense which by the way is
legal under international law
unlike the russian invasion which is
illegal under international law
western supply of weapons including
heavy weapons including offensive
weapons to ukraine for its self-defense
in the invasion by russia is actually
legal under and so
thank god the ukrainians
surprised everybody
they surprised me they surprised putin
and the kremlin they surprised the bidet
administration they surprised the
european union
not with the fact that they would resist
we knew that
we had the orange revolution in 2004 we
had maidan in 2013-14
where they rose up against
a domestic tyrant
and they were willing to die on behalf
of their country then let alone against
the foreign tyrant invading their
country right
so we knew they would resist we didn't
know just how successful certainly i
didn't know they would be on the
battlefield it's been breathtaking to
watch
that sacrifice that gift
enabled the west to rediscover itself to
rediscover its power to revive itself to
say to hell with this energy dependence
in the long term the hell with this
money laundering and reputation
laundering the hell with this running
back and forth to moscow
to try to see what putin needs in order
for him to feel respected what
appeasement he needs right so so
we'll see if it endures
but this
shift
comes from the ukrainians and so it's no
longer getting away with murder lex and
we thank the ukrainians for that the
people and the leadership
and uh
the the separate factions that make up
ukraine uniting the it's the unification
the uniting against the common enemy yes
and standing up
before anyone knew that they would be
backed by all of these other nations by
this money and all this kind of stuff
standing there
especially with the president zolensky
where it makes uh total sense to flee
he stood his ground
and let's take that point that you just
raised which is a deep and fundamental
point and i thank you for that
do you guys hear that though i think
that was a compliment there we go let's
go
alex silence your unification i'm
sitting here in front of you thank you
it's an honor and and it's a mutual
honor
so um
ukraine before the war
is run by a tv production company
right you're one guy running this
fantastic incredible podcast there's 20
guys or so running a country the size of
ukraine yeah
and and one's a producer and one's like
a makeup person and
one's a video editor and they're
fantastically talented people
if your country is a tv production
so before the war zelensky had what 25
percent approval rating
and he couldn't get much done and it
wasn't working he got elected with 73 as
you know and then he was down to 20
that's a pretty big drop
and so you're thinking maybe having a
major large size 40 million plus
population european country run by a tv
production company is not the best
choice
and then what do we see
we see president zielenski decides
to risk his life on behalf of his
country ukraine he decides to stay in
the capital
he's not going to flee
he they're going to stay and fight
and he could be killed he can die it's a
decision where he put his life on the
line
obviously
he's jewish descent
russian speaking
childhood and upbringing
russian speaking jewish descent puts his
life on the line for the country of
ukraine
it's a pretty big message don't you
think
and it's crucial
and it turns out not only that lex but
they're good at tv
they're good at information war
and in a war yeah it's a tv production
company and a tv personality those
that's exactly what you want running a
country
because they're crushing in the
information war and he's spectacular
european parliament
u.s congress israeli parliament there's
no room
on zoom let alone in person
that he can't win over he's just so
effective you know this is the first
time reality tv
has been about reality
instead of fake
reality tv is just this completely fake
nonsense
but zelensky this is real reality tv
and and and he means it
and and the nation is behind him
and and they're just as courageous and
just as ingenious in many ways and it's
spectacular
and so yeah
who saw that coming i didn't see that
coming lex in fact dubai didn't we talk
about putin's miscalculation the bide
administration as you alluded to
offered him an exit from the country
they didn't say you know you want to
stand and fight we'll back you
they said we'll get you out
you want to come now
and famously you know that quote
right what he said
about how he doesn't need a ride
remember that yeah moment
the administration was poised to do
another afghanistan moment
that ignominious exit from afghanistan
was almost what happened in ukraine
when by the administration offered him
that ride out of there and fortunately
he declined and helped rally and the
people from below also rallied to stop
the invader
without the presidency and without the
government in ukraine
saving the biden administration and and
the european leaders
who latched on fortunately they had the
presence of mind to latch onto this gift
this this
bravery and ingeniousness of of celenski
and the rest of the ukrainians and
flipped and decided to support ukraine's
resistance
you know first with 5 000 helmets only
as the germans initially promised and
now with really heavy weapons
and so that's something that wasn't
foreseen
i certainly didn't foresee that i
foresaw the ukrainian society being
courageous and resisting but i didn't
foresee a television production company
being exactly what you want to run a
country in a war
a president
zielenski
willing to sacrifice lay down his life
and rallying others in the country to do
that and then the country being so
effective
not just at
a courage but at battlefield resistance
to the russian invasion
so i stand corrected by the ukrainians
and i'm ecstatic that i didn't that i
was wrong that i was proven wrong and
like i said there's
clear factions of the west and the east
of ukraine and here's a person that like
you said was in the high 20s low 30s
percentage
approval
in the country before the war and now
was able to use in the 90s in the 90s
he's in the 90
approval rating i mean i i think they
stopped doing
the uh
the polling once he hit 91 percent or
whatever it was in the previous poll i
think they all understood that for now
they didn't need any more polling
that it's pretty clear the nation so 25
percent to 90 something percent
and and and just like the 25 percent was
deserved
the 90-something percent is also
deserved fully deserved and the question
is how that all stabilizes
it feels
like
this
set of events
i may be
paying attention to twitter too much
which is a concern uh
of mine whether
the change i see is just surface level
or deep level but it seems like we're in
a new world that something dramatic has
shifted
that
um this
power that's rooted i mean in your study
it
uh
of the 20th century it's so deeply
rooted in history there's this power
center of the world
is now
going to it has been shaken by this
event and how that changes the world is
is unclear
uh it's unclear what lesson china learns
from watching this well lesson india
learns from watching this both nations
as far as you can get polls about
chinese population
but both nations are largely in support
of putin
so russia india and china are still
supporting of putin
quietly i would maybe
elaborate a little bit on that point lex
i think you're right the feeling that
we're in an inflection moment you know
an inflection point
i think that's widespread and i think
it's widespread for good reason we might
be but i also share
uh your um
let's say
modesty
about
where it's going
and how hard it is to predict where this
might go
it's only an inflection point if the
trends continue
right if the trends endure
there are plenty of non-inflection
points
after 9 11 the whole world rallied
around the united states after it was
attacked
after the
the bombing of the towers here in new
york city and the hitting of the
pentagon
and and that didn't last
and it was not really an inflection
point was it
it felt like it might be but it wasn't
and so this is not a comparable moment
in in terms of what happened
uh but it has the feeling that it might
be a watershed
and maybe we'll squander it the way we
squandered the post-911
uh rallying around the united states
maybe we'll actually consolidate it and
it'll endure or maybe it'll endure
despite ourselves
and we can't tell and we can't know yet
and it depends in part on what we do and
what we don't do
but here's a few things that we
understand already
the idea that the west was in decline
and that the rest of the world had risen
and was more powerful and that we lived
in a multi-polar world
that turns out to be empirically false
it's not true
i mean it's just factually not true
there are no major important
multinational institutions organizations
that are run
on behalf of or led by
a south african
a nigerian
person from india
even the chinese
don't run these institutions they would
like to and they're trying
but they don't
and so whatever you pick the imf the
world bank
the federal reserve which is the most
powerful multinational institution which
is actually
only a domestic institution and doesn't
have
a legal mandate to act multilaterally
but does
it's got the most power of any
institution in the world
nato
the bilateral alliances that the us has
up and down asia
what organizations
that have tremendous leverage on the
international system on the
international order are non-western
the un
is the most
encompassing and of course we know that
the five it has five members of the
security council with a veto
one of which is russia one of which is
china and the others are the us
britain and france
not india
not south africa
not indonesia
not all of these other countries where
the people live
right the bulk of the population of the
world
and where the population is growing like
on the african continent
so it's not a multi-polar world
we talked already about the
international financial system
that's the western not multi-polar we
talked about the us military and nato or
we could talk about the japanese
military which is just very formidable
enormous number of platforms
even the australian military we could
talk about likes right
and so it's a western dominated world
and the west remember is not a
geographic concept
it is an institutional and values
club
the japanese are not european but
they're western
just like russia is european but not
western
because european is a cultural category
and western is an institutional category
where you have rule of law and
separation of powers and free and open
public sphere and dynamic open market
economy and
okay
and then we have another thing which is
pretty clear
the west is powerfully resented
powerfully envied and admired
simultaneously
pj o'rourke
the comedian who died this year
fantastic it was a big loss for the
culture
he said there are two things that are
always characteristic of any american
embassy abroad
one is a political protest
outside
and the other is the longest line you've
ever seen
for visas
and those things are true simultaneously
and that's the world we live in meaning
that non-western countries
envy and admire the west but they also
resent the power of the west
western hypocrisy
right the west
invades countries
when it wants but when others do that
it's illegal
right the west
uh arrests you for
money laundering but it's western money
laundering that is where you go when you
need to launder money right so
they see the hypocrisy they see the
excessive power
that the west has
and they resent it
and they say
you who elected you to run the world
we have a billion plus people or we have
a 200 plus million people and we don't
have a say
you're the self-appointed guardians of
our world who did that and so it's
incumbent on the west not only to
remember
the power that it has
but also to exercise that power legally
and with restraint
and also to think about how we can
expand institutions
to be more encompassing
so that other parts of the world are not
on the outside
being dictated to
but instead are on the inside
too often
right
western power
is not consultative
in a decision-making fashion
it's consultative after the fact
okay you know we got together in the eu
or we got together
in nato or we got together at the
federal reserve and here's our decision
and we're announcing it today
and so your economy gets destroyed
because the federal reserve decides it
has to raise interest rates
or
you now uh go into default you can't pay
your debt because western banks lent you
money
and now the west has changed interest
rates or or other considerations
and you're in big trouble now and so
this is something which we fail to
address
it's very hard to address it's very hard
to reform international institutions
it's very hard to share power
it's very hard to acknowledge that you
have too much power
and that maybe having too much power
is not good not only for the rest of the
world but for yourself
and so it's great to rediscover the west
and rediscover its values and rediscover
its authority and credibility and power
but it's that's not sufficient so we
know this now we know that the rest of
the world
is not necessarily
jumping on the western bandwagon
right to condemn russia for its actions
because the west can
do things like sanction your central
bank
take away your reserves
deny you technology it pretty much can
do whatever it wants and it can say that
it's legal and it can go through various
mechanisms and
and it can freeze your property and
and you say to yourself should anybody
have that much power and
when do they come after me now there's a
caveat here
and the caveat likes is
they don't
like the west having all of that power
and they didn't join in the condemnation
of russia
but they also didn't join in russia's
aggression
so russia's
domestic civilian
aerospace aircraft industry right
civilian aircraft industry is in big
trouble now
because of the export controls
on spare parts and software
brazil
is a major power in aircraft
manufacturing did they rush in
and say you know
vladimir putin we didn't condemn
necessarily your actions in ukraine okay
that's one thing and how about we give
you all of our aircraft technology and
we help you rebuild
your domestic aircraft industry and you
can have the aviation that the western
did that happen lex
didn't happen
and you can look at india and you can
look at china and you can look at south
africa and you can look at what they've
done in practical terms
yes
they haven't always joined in a
full-throated condemnation maybe they've
been neutral or maybe they've been
playing both sides of the fence like
turkey for example
but are they rushing in
to join russia
to join russia's aggression to supply
and the answer is no
and the answer is no for two reasons
one they actually don't want to be party
to that
and two
they understand that western power
and and they don't want to be on the
receiving end
by crossing the west and then getting
caught up in a sanctions regime or worse
you